my name is dr. John Chapman and the
chief executive and director general its
international institute for strategic
studies which is based in London but
isn't this national think tank with
individual important members in over a
hundred countries in the world and
facilitation in Washington are in
Singapore I just come from sharing a
quick session of the World Economic
Forum at Davos and the what if question
was what if Iran gets nuclear weapons
and we had a splendid array of
participants in Queens Authority defence
minister as well mano to ten regional
international atomic energy agency
president yeah richard has counseled
correlations in New York City and cut a
phenomena he the Chairman vision three
days to get it essentially we grappled a
great deal with the question of what is
the threshold to define whether Iran has
another military commander there three
elements doing another capacity firstly
sufficient a fissile material in order
to make a ball second in creation of an
actual know the device and third and
miniaturization of that device and
multiply sment on a ballistic missile in
order to behave deliver a nuclear strike
in order to make it noticeably nuclear
test some might even go further and say
that unless one had an awesome doesn't
it more nuclear weapons one can't really
speak of a country as possession of the
interesting craves it evaporates from
our discussion was soon of immunity was
reduced by include power to define what
concerns him there would come a point at
which Iran would be able to place its
activities in all three of those areas
in underground or beyond the week
inspectors thereby creating for itself
is your communication beyond the reach
of America strike and Beyond influence
economic political
the appeal that came from any bar was
for those who are genuinely concerned
about what a world would look like with
an Iranian nuclear weapons the pace of
sanctions now has to be picked up ok no
longer is debate about their utility the
patient 0 seconds while hospital there
was an implicit acceptance there were
limitations of what could be done with a
military strike Israel could have
reformed away the United States and much
larger and sophisticated campaign but
the ability to assess them not to
destroy all of the runs question though
and the only victory will be a delay in
your intestine there were dif interviews
as to whether an Iran with nuclear
weapons would pose a major danger they
representatives from Israel in the
United States and definitely feeling it
would the representative from the Arab
world wondering whether make such a huge
a strategic difference and from China
but it lived with a North Korea with
nuclear weapons are also a more relaxed
rash but it's clear that the question of
nuclear weapons from Iran is not only a
concern for Israel United States many
golfers our monarchies and governments
are equally concerned as are others who
feel that an Iran with nuclear weapons
would promote morning correlation region
by takeo eaten retina degrading debate
we didn't reach a conclusion but this
new term of art was put on the table a
sort of immunities and look for the
debate in the international press and
amongst experts and governments to be
focused to get more on this term Jonah
balloon Booth has people calculated by
the sanctions for work or perhaps a
military strike don't need to pretend to
adorn the dangerous kohler with that
region tale